l'impression que ce débat donné c'était
que quand on met le programme de Marine
Le Pen face à un contradicteur qui a
l'expérience du pouvoir et bien c'est
beaucoup moins solide
pour notre pays c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle parce que vous dépendez du
pouvoir russe et que vous dépendez de
Monsieur Poutine et donc vous ne parlez
pas à d'autres dirigeants vous parlez à
votre banquier quand vous parlez de la
Russie c'est ça le problème Madame Le
Pen alors peut-être que c'est aussi ce
qui ce qui fait que on le voit bien dès
qu'il y a des positions courageuses et
difficiles à prendre
ni vous niveau représentants de son là
bonjour à tous pour commencer je
voudrais remercier le Figaro de me
permettre de débriefer ce débat avec
vous je sais que c'est un débat
important je voudrais également dire en
propos préliminaires voilà je suis juste
quelqu'un qui aime le discours je suis
juste un analyste tout ça pour vous dire
que votre vote vous allez le faire avec
votre votre intime conviction et vous
n'avez pas à vous laisser influencer par
ce que je vais dire pourquoi est-ce que
je commence par ce préliminaire parce
que ce que je vais vous dire c'est que
j'ai vu un débat déséquilibré alors bien
sûr vous allez pouvoir contester mon
analyse les commentaires sont faits pour
ça le premier point c'est que Marine Le
Pen cherchait à ne pas reproduire la la
performance de la dernière fois donc la
stratégie qu'elle avait adopté la
première fois dans son premier débat
avec Macron c'était de d'être agressive
et c'était une bonne stratégie il faut
comprendre qu'on gagne un débat quand on
parvient à mettre notre adversaire plus
longtemps que nous dans une position
désagréable sur un sujet qu'il n'aime
pas et en position d'accuser parce que
je regardais votre programme vos 22
mesures il n'y a même pas le mot chômage
dedans
qui frappant et pas de problème alors je
veux c'est une reconnaissance du travail
bien fait pour les 5 années qui viennent
de s'écouler je vous en remercie cette
fois elle allait être plus concentrée
sur son propre programme que sur le
programme de Macron elle devait donc
être moins agressive cette stratégie ne
lui a pas rendu service elle a beaucoup
plus souvent laisser Macron dérouler je
voudrais pas que celles et ceux qui nous
écoutent pensent qu'avec vous leur
salaire va augmenter de 10% automatique
pardon mais je crois ce que je peux
revenir au blocage des prix Madame Le
Pen parce que je suis content
d'apprendre que vous le maintenez mais
vous avez voté contre quand il est passé
à l'Assemblée donc je dis juste que
votre programme n'est que ni tête et ce
qui était très frappant c'était que
alors que Marine Le Pen quand elle
faisait des réponses et bien elle elle
se focalisait sur son programme Macron
commençait systématiquement ses
interventions par une attaque d'abord je
prend note des positions de Madame Le
Pen qui ne correspondent pas opposition
que votre partie et vos parlementaire
défendent Parlement européen par
parenthèse et qu'il s'agisse de protéger
jésus-christiens quand ils viennent sur
notre sol comme des sanctions
additionnelles après le premier paquet
comme de l'aide à l'Ukraine d'ailleurs à
laquelle vous êtes aussi opposé l'aide
financière c'est faux non c'est un fait
Madame Le Pen c'est faux ce sont les
votes et c'est d'ailleurs ce que vous
venez de dire complètement le contraire
des positions que vous avez
historiquement tenues c'est Macron qui
dans ce débat a introduit de la
contradiction Macron était offensif et
Marine Le Pen était plutôt inoffensive
elle a donc laissé trop de confort à
Macron ce débat est censé être une
opportunité pour Marine Le Pen de
montrer qu'ils avaient bien travaillé
qu'ils avaient un programme chiffré et
bien Emmanuel Macron avait très
régulièrement a pu montrer que sur tel
aspect tel aspect précis du programme il
y avait des choses qui ne tenaient pas
je ne dis pas que le programme de Marine
Le Pen ne tient pas ce que je dis c'est
que l'impression que ce débat de donnait
c'était que quand on met le programme de
Marine Le Pen face à un contradicteur
qui a l'expérience du pouvoir et bien
c'est beaucoup moins solide parce que je
souhaite changer le système de fond en
comble parce que je veux rester contre
le blocage des prix parce que je veux
restituer aux Français un des prix de
l'énergie qui sont la conséquence de
l'investissement de leur part de leur
pays européens pas autre chose Monsieur
mais monsieur Macron je pensais pas que
vous tomberiez dans une forme de
complotisme je n'ai je ne souhaite pas
en sortir si vous souhaitez
en sortir je le dirai si je dis que je
ne souhaite pas en sortir c'est que je
ne souhaite pas le faire donc 80% du
programme a changé c'est une bonne
nouvelle par rapport à 5 ans puisque 80%
étaient applicable sans euros mais je
vais revenir sur ce que vous disiez
d'abord dans votre programme il y a de
fait
changer tout seul un club en réduisant
sa cotisation en disant je choisis mes
règles
soit les autres vous suivent parce que
c'est ça l'Europe on est 27 autour de la
table soit vous faites bande à part et
le fait est que quand elle essayait de
dérouler là-dessus elle s'est fait
contrer par des éléments factuels et pas
quelque chose de provisoire que vous
avez fait c'est contre le fait de
manière provisoire vous avez compris
le bouclier vous êtes un peu confus vous
avez supprimé les mathématiques vous les
avez rétablis
et défait alors c'est la défaire c'est
toujours travailler d'accord mais ça
démontre quand même un problème de
vision
je pensais que Macron allait très en
difficulté sur le ciel du pouvoir
d'achat et c'est important parce que
c'est le sujet qui arrive en premier
c'est le sujet sur lequel il y a le plus
de gens qui regardent le débat et donc
sur ce sujet là Macron n'a pas été mis
en difficulté on a senti que Marine Le
Pen n'avait pas la volonté de l'attaquer
j'ai par exemple été frappé du fait
qu'elle n'a pas mis le scandale McKinsey
sur la table parce que la la réforme que
vous proposez est une réforme qui
consiste à payer les professeurs en
fonction des résultats de leurs élèves
je sais pas c'est McKinsey qui a proposé
ça y est je l'attendais celle-là mais en
l'espèce
non je pense que ça peut être ça peut
être là franchement pour le coup ça peut
être eux il avait pas vraiment envie de
le déstabiliser elle s'en est tenue à sa
stratégie si bien que sur les sujets ou
ça aurait été le plus facile de mettre
Macron dans une situation délicate elle
ne l'a pas fait alors que de son côté
Emmanuel Macron a été beaucoup plus
intransigeant que la dernière fois
Emmanuel Macron a été très offensif mon
problème Madame Le Pen vous le
reconnaîtrez avec moi c'est que ceci
créé une dépendance mais votre prêt n'a
pas été contracté auprès d'une banque
lambda même en Russie mais auprès des
intérêts et du pouvoir et chacun pourra
le vérifier et donc assumez-le c'est
tout assumez-le Madame Le Pen et
beaucoup de vos choix derrière
s'explique par cette dépendance mais ça
n'est pas je ne vous en fais pas grief
je dis simplement que d'autres candidats
défendant des idées proches des vôtres
n'ont pas fait les mêmes choix et qu'ils
ont trouvé des financements
dans des banques françaises européennes
que vous vous avez fait un choix qui
manifestement vous a ensuite contraint
dans votre position politique et qui ne
vous rend pas indépendante sur cette
question c'est un fait c'est faux je
vous le redis
on est tous à vous écouter c'est quand
même assez malhonnête monsieur Macron
la manière dont Marine Le Pen va pouvoir
sauver la face c'est de dire que elle
était face à quelqu'un qui était
arrogant face à quelqu'un qui était
méprisant face à quelqu'un qui ne se
préoccupe pas des vrais sujets des
Français elle a réussi tout au long du
débat essayer de construire une image de
moi je suis proche du point de vue des
Français je suis prof du peuple d'abord
je suis obligé là encore d'être le
porte-parole des Français et donc face à
elle on avait quelqu'un qui était plus
factuel qui était moins dans l'émotion
et du coup qui avait l'air un peu moins
humain un peu moins empathique donc sur
ce plan là ça a marché elle n'a pas
réussi selon moi changer de dimension
elle a réussi à se tenir à la stratégie
qui s'était fixée à savoir pas de
dérapage et donc le débat était beaucoup
plus courtois et quand on parlait du
fond des sujets et bien elle était
manifestement assez régulièrement
dépassée par quelqu'un qui est rompu à
l'exercice du pouvoir encore une fois
c'est mon analyse personnelle c'est une
analyse à chaud et je vous laisse
maintenant si vous le souhaitez discuter
de mon analyse dans les commentaires